WELL GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYONE I
WAS --
WAITING A COUPLE MOMENTS FOR OUR
FELLOW COLLEAGUE A REPUBLICAN.
VICE CHAIR --
I'VE BEEN TOLD HE'S ON HIS WAY
SO THAT'S WHY HADN'T AND GET
STARTED.
AS COMMITTEES.
ME THE WHOLE UNTIL WE GET TO
MISTER VOEPEL HERE.
AND SO I DON'T.
THINK YOU'RE GOING TO BEING HERE
THANK YOU BOTH A SANDERS ARE
BEING IN A TIMELY FASHION AS
WELL AS MY COLLEAGUES.
AND WELCOME TO OUR COMMITTEE ON
AGING LONG TERM CARE HEARING
LIKE TO WELCOME.
SAMBA COM LET LET IT GO --
FOR BEING HERE AND JOINING US
I'M REALLY HAPPY TO HAVE HER ON
THE COMMITTEE.
WE DO HAVE THREE BILLS IMPALA
ORDER HOWEVER A SENATOR HAD AT
JACKSON'S RIGHT NOW SHARING HER
COMMITTEE SO WILL GO NEXT IN
ORDER WHICH IS SENATOR HUESOS --
BILL.
AND SO CENTER PLEASE.
TAKE A SEAT [inaudible]
AND THIS IS.
S. B. ELEVEN NINETY ONE TO
PROCEED WHENEVER YOU'RE READY
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND THANK THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS. ELEVEN NINETY ONE SIX
TO IMPROVE THE WELL BEING.
OF A VULNERABLE POPULATION BY
MANDATING THE CALIFORNIA PENAL
CODE.
THREE SIXTY EIGHT THE REFERENCES
STATE LAW ENFORCEMENT.
MANUALS SO IT'S A VERY SIMPLE --
LAW THAT SAY --
AT THREE SIXTY IT IS TO BE ARE
INCLUDED IN THE MANUALS.
WELL WE WE HAVE EMPIRICAL DATA
THAT WE HAVE A SPEAKER THIS
SPEAKS TO THE FACT THAT --
SIMPLY BY BUT I MEAN THE LAW TO
THE MANUAL IT WOULD --
TRAIN OFFICERS ACCORDINGLY GIVE
THEM THE INFORMATION.
INFORMATION THEY NEED. TO
IDENTIFY CASES OF ELDER ELDER
ABUSE.
AND BASIC GIVES GIVE SOME --
UP BETTER UNDERSTANDING HOW TO
TREAT THOSE CASES.
IT'S TO THIS PINNACLE IS IS
MEANT TO BE IMPLEMENTED ON A
STATEWIDE BASIS.
MOST LOCAL LAWS IT ENFORCEMENT
TUITIONS HAVE ELDER.
OR DEPENDENT ADULT POLICIES TO
FILL TWO REFERENCES PENAL CODE.
WHICH MEANS THAT --
MANY OF THESE CASES ARE NOT BEEN
IDENTIFIED --
EVEN IF A IN IN THE CASES
RELATING --
TO HOW A HOW THIS INFORMATION IS
DISSEMINATED --
ONE OF THE PRODUCERS OF MANUALS
ALEXA POLL --
IT DOESN'T EVEN AT THIS TO THEIR
TO THEIR MANUALS AND IT'S
CREATING PROBLEMS FOR THE
ELDERLY ELDER COMMUNITY.
WE HAVE LEASE AGAIN AND WITH THE
SAN JOSE POLICE DEPARTMENT WHO.
WHO WAS INSTRUMENTAL IN
IMPLEMENTING THESE --
FEE NOT CODES IN SAN JOSE'S
POLICE DEPARTMENT WHO'S DONE A
GREAT JOB ON THIS ISSUE AND I AT
IF THE SHIRT CHAIR WOULD ALLOW.
HER TO JUST PRESENT HOW THIS IS
WORK SO THE SAN JOSE COMMUNITY I
I HAVE A SPECIAL PLACE IN MY
HEART FOR THIS HOUSE AT LEAST
BUY ME FLOWERS PLEASE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING
ME TO TESTIFY AND SENATE BILL.
ELEVEN NINETY ONE MY NAME IS
LISA GANON I'M LIEUTENANT WITH
THE SAN JOSE POLICE DEPARTMENT I
OFFER MY SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL
IS I BELIEVE MANDATING LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO INCLUDE PENAL
CODE THREE SIXTY EIGHT IN THE
POLICY MANUALS.
AS WELL AS IN THEIR TRAINING
WILL ASSIST THOSE IMPROPERLY
IDENTIFYING INSTANCES OF ELDER
INDEPENDENT ADULT ABUSE.
IN THE LONG RUN THIS WILL HELP
ENSURE THE SAFETY AND WELL BEING
OF OUR OLDER INDEPENDENT ADULT
POPULATIONS THROUGH PROPER AND
THOROUGH REPORTING.
IN TWENTY FIFTEEN I WAS THE UNIT
COMMANDER FOR THE FAMILY
VIOLENCE UNIT WHICH INVESTIGATES
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE CHILD ABUSE
RESTRAINING ORDER VIOLATIONS AN
ELDER INDEPENDENT ADULT ABUSE.
I WAS ASKED FIRE DEPARTMENT TO
REVIEW OUR POLICY AND IMPROVE
ITS CONTENTS.
I SPENT ALMOST NINE MONTHS
WORKING ON THE PROJECT AS I
CONSULTED WITH ADULT PROTECTIVE
SERVICES IN THE LOCAL DISTRICT
ATTORNEY.
I ALSO RELIED HEAVILY ON THE
SANTA CLARA COUNTY ELDER
INDEPENDENT ADULT ABUSE PROTOCOL
WHICH IS READILY AVAILABLE
ONLINE.
I WANTED TO ENSURE THAT OUR
POLICY INCLUDED BEST PRACTICES
FOR INVESTIGATING REPORTING AND
CROSS REPORTING.
ELDER INDEPENDENT ADULT ABUSE.
FUND OF AMBER FIFTH TWENTY
FIFTEEN I ROLLED OUT THE SAN
JOSE POLICE DEPARTMENT TRAINING
BULLETIN.
AND A COMPREHENSIVE POLICY
UPDATE TO EVERY OFFICER WORKING
IN PATROL.
THE TRAINING BULLETIN IN THE NEW
POLICY CONTAINED CLEAR
REFERENCES TO PENAL CODE
SECTION.
THREE SIXTY EIGHT IN THE YEARS
TO FOLLOW I CHECKED WITH OUR
RESEARCH AND DEVELOPMENT TO SEE
HOW MANY CASES OF ELDER ABUSE
WERE BEING REPORTED.
IN THE FIRST YEAR THEY DOUBLED
IN THE SECOND YEAR THE NUMBER OF
REPORTS TRIPLED.
I BELIEVE THE INCREASE IN
REPORTING IS DUE TO THE SAN JOSE
POLICE DEPARTMENT BEING BETTER
EDUCATED AS TO WHAT TO LOOK FOR
IN THE HOME AND THE IMPORTANCE
OF DOCUMENTING SUSPECTED.
AND ACTUAL ABUSE OR NEGLECT.
DURING MY TIME THE FAMILY
VIOLENCE UNIT I WAS FORTUNATE TO
SERVICE THE SUBJECT MATTER
EXPERTS ON A TRAINING VIDEO.
WHICH WAS PUT OUT BY THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA COMMISSION ON
PEACE OFFICERS STANDARDS AND
TRAINING ALSO KNOWN AS POST.
THIS COMPREHENSIVE TRAINING
VIDEO IS FREE TO ALL LAW
ENFORCEMENT YOU BELONG TO POST.
THE VIDEO FOCUSES ON
SAFEGUARDING ELDER INDEPENDENT
ADULTS IS WELL AS PROVIDING
EDUCATION ON RESPONDING TO IN
ASSISTING ELDERS AND THE
IMPORTANCE OF PROPER ACCORDING.
WELL MY EXPERIENCE AND EXPOSURE
IS LIMITED TO THE SAN JOSE
POLICE DEPARTMENT MY LAW
ENFORCEMENT INTUITION TELLS ME
THAT TRAINING AND AND EDUCATION
OF FIRST RESPONDERS IS CRITICAL
TO IDENTIFYING IN INTERVENING ON
BEHALF OF ELDERS INDEPENDENT
ADULTS.
WHO ARE BEING VICTIMIZED?
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR LETTING ME
TESTIFY [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
UP BEFORE PRE MOVE ON THAT SIDE
FOR CAN STOP A SQUARE
[inaudible]
KALRA [inaudible]
HERE [inaudible]
VOEPEL.
ALAN COVER GYRO [inaudible]
GLORIA [inaudible]
YOU'RE [inaudible]
KAMLAGER-DOVE [inaudible]
RUBIO.
SO WE HAVE TO OF QUORUM
ESTABLISHED.
I THINK YOU FOR TESTIMONY OTHER
ANY OTHER OF ANYONE ELSE LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
NAME AFFILIATION POSITION THANK
YOU TREES ANDERSON ON THE HELP
OF THE ARCANE UCP CALIFORNIA
COLLABORATION AND SUPPORT.
RAINY HICKS CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE
RETIRED AMERICANS CALIFORNIA
THROUGH DISABILITY RIGHTS IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
I'M PHYLLIS KAULBACH AND MY
FAMILY AND MY FATHER HAVE BEEN
VICTIMS OF PROFESSIONAL
CRIMINALS.
RICHARD CALHOUN WITH CEDAR VERY
MUCH IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
JEFF TOWARD A KIA ADVOCATE.
CARA HOW.
OTHER ORGANIZATIONS AND ARE.
GOOD THAT SEE WOULD RIVERSIDE
STERLING.
LINDA KING CAVE WITH THE
COALITION OF ELDER DISABILITY
RIGHTS THE LETTUCE BEING HANDED
OUT TO YOU RIGHT NOW IS FROM THE
SHERIFF OF SANFORD ST BOOKED ON
A BARBARA COUNTY.
TELLING ME THAT HE IS REFERRING
A CRIMINAL COMPLAINT TO SOCIAL
SERVICES THAT'S WHY WE NEED THIS
BILL AND WHY WE SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
ALRIGHT THANK YOU SO MUCH ANYONE
IN OPPOSITION.
OKAY SO ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS OR MOTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SO WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE TABLE
--
WOULD AGE LIKE TO CLOSE UNDER
COMPLETE ASKING FOR YOUR SUPPORT
TODAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU AND THANK YOU SO MUCH OF
BRING THIS IMPORTANT WHAT WE DO
WITH THIS ISSUE A LOT.
INTERNS ELDER ABUSE SO THANK YOU
FOR YOUR WORK.
RIGHT UP WE CAN GO.
CALL THE ROLL.
KALRA.
AYE KALRA AYE VOEPEL.
VOEPEL AYE.
ALLEN [inaudible]
COVER GYRO.
GLORIA AYE GLORIA AYE.
KAMLAGER-DOVE [inaudible]
KAMLAGER-DOVE I RUBIO.
THE BILL US OUT.
I THINK.
YOU CENTER UNKNOWABLE LEAVE THE
ROLE OPEN FOR FOLKS THAT ARE
HERE.
SENATOR --
GAMES SP.
TWELVE FORTY EIGHT IT'S BOTTOM.
THREE THANK YOU AT YOUR CALDERON
INVESTORS THAT WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY SENATOR GREAT THANK YOU --
THIS IS WITH REGARDS TO SENATE
BILL.
TWELVE FORTY EIGHT AND PASS OUT
BABY BOOMERS REACH THEIR
SEVENTIES AND EIGHTIES.
EXPERTS ANTICIPATE A SURGE IN
DEMAND. FOR LONG TERM CARE
SERVICES.
A CALIFORNIA PARTNERSHIP FOR
LONG TERM CARE IS THE STATE
EFFORT INTENDED TO HELP.
MIDDLE CLASS CONSUMERS PAY FOR
THAT CARE.
THE PARTNERSHIP CERTIFIES THAT
SPECIAL INSURANCE POLICIES
PROVIDE A UNIQUE ASSET
PROTECTION FEATURE.
IF THAT IN SHORT OF ACTUALLY
APPLIES FOR MEDICARE ALSO
NURSING HOME BENEFIT THESE
POLICIES HELP.
POLICY HOLDERS AVOID IN PARTNERS
IMPOVERISHMENT.
BUT CURRENT PARTNERSHIP
STANDARDS.
REQUIRE EXTENSIVE BENEFITS AND
THE POLICIES ARE ON AFFORDABLE
TO MIDDLE CLASS CONSUMERS.
SALES HAVE DWINDLED AND MOST
INSURERS OF LEFT THE PROGRAM.
S. B. TWELVE FORTY EIGHT TAKES
IMMEDIATE STEPS TO MAKE POLICIES
MORE AFFORDABLE BY UPDATING THE
PROGRAM STANDARDS. TO ALLOW MORE
FLEXIBILITY THIS BILL FOLLOWS UP
ON SENATE BILL THIRTEEN EIGHTY
FOUR AND ACTED IN.
TWENTY SIXTEEN AND IS THE RESULT
OF COOPERATIVE EFFORTS WITH
INTERESTED STAKE HOLDERS AND THE
SENATE INSURANCE COMMITTEE.
Q. SLAYTON FROM THE SENATE
INSURANCE COMMITTEES AVAILABLE
TO ANSWER.
AND A QUESTION.
THANK YOU MUCH SIR OF MANY
WITNESSES.
I DIDN'T HAVE TO CREATE IT OKAY
GREAT EVEN BETTER.
ALRIGHT.
BUT NOT THAT YOU WERE UNCLEAR.
FIVE AND ANYONE ELSE WHO SUPPORT
[inaudible]
PERSONAL ASSOCIATION.
I HAVE INSURANCE.
AND PENINSULA PRIZES.
AS CHAIR MEMBERS JOHN SHRIEKING
ON BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA LIFE AND HEALTH
INSURANCE COMPANIES.
AS WE TWELVE FORTY IT'S A GOOD
BILL AND I THINK IT'S A STEP IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION PLEASE
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
SO MUCH ANYONE OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
POSTS ARE.
WHO SORRY BUT THAT ADVOCATE OF
HOME WHAT REVIEWING WHAT'S GOING
ON?
I JUST WARN VIA SENATOR OF
UNINTENTIONAL CONSEQUENCES.
BUT IT'S A STEP.
SO SUPPORT IT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WHAT IN OPPOSITION?
WE GET BACK TO THE COMMITTEE AND
IT'S A PLEASURE.
JUST A QUICK COMMENT TO THE
AUTHOR.
THIS IS SPOT ON I WAS A HIGH END
INSURANCE BROKER. FOR THIRTY
NINE YEARS.
AND WAS LICENSE TO SELL LONG
TERM CARE INSURANCE.
AND I MUST'VE MADE THIRTY FIVE
MAYBE FORTY QUOTES NEVER SOLD
ONE POLICY [inaudible]
EVEN [inaudible]
WITH THE PREVIOUSLY OWES THAT
THE THAT THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
GAVE -- THIS.
DOES HELP REYES THE LIMITS FOR
THE PARTNERSHIP PLAN. TO SOME
LEVEL THAT I CAN LOWER THE PRICE
OF THE PEOPLE COULD ACTUALLY
AFFORD IT.
SO.
I LOOK UPON THIS IS A FIRST
STEP.
BECAUSE HERE'S WHAT HAPPENS IN
THE MARKETPLACE.
PEOPLE WANT THE LONG TERM CARE
INSURANCE BUT AT THE TWO HUNDRED
EIGHTY AND THREE HUNDRED DOLLARS
THE DAY IT TAKES YOU TO BE
CERTAIN.
OF HOME.
THEY CAN'T AFFORD IT THE PREMIUM
IS OUTRAGEOUSLY HIGH.
AND THAT'S JUST THE WAY IT'S
GONNA BE UNLESS SOME GOVERNMENT.
COMES IN AND SUBSIDIZES THIS IS
THE BEST WAY IN THE MOST
EFFICIENT WAY WE CAN SUBSIDIZES
PROGRAM.
I HOPE IT CATCHES ON AT LEAST
FOR SOME OF THE MIDDLE CLASS.
SO I APPLAUD YOU SIR THANK YOU
THIS IS GREAT.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR A MOTION.
ALRIGHT SO WE HAVE A MOTION ON
THE TABLE AND EYES Y. THANK YOU
SENATOR THIS IS AN ISSUE ABOUT
LAST YEAR BEEN BUT IT
INFORMATION HEARINGS AROUND THE
STATE INCLUDING IN SAN DIEGO AND
LOS ANGELES THE PERSONS AND SAN
JOSE SPECIFICALLY DEALT.
WITH LONG TERM CARE FINANCING
AND THE CRISIS WERE IN THIS IS
NOT UP PLEASE FIX OF IT BUT IS
DEATHLY A STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTIONS CAN OFFER.
MORE OPTIONS SO I I FULLY
SUPPORT THE BILL AND THANK YOU
FOR OFFERING IT. TO HAVE
WONDERFUL THANK YOU SO MUCH IT
WAS UGLY ANY CLOSING COMMENTS
YEP -- THANK
YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION --
OF THE BILL I THINK IT'S JUST
ONE PIECE. TO MAKE SURE THAT
THERE'S AVAILABILITY.
AND HOPEFULLY PRICE
STABILIZATION.
AND LONG TERM HEALTH CARE.
SO THANK YOU. FOR JULY VOTE.
THEN SO WE DO HAVE UP.
A BILL ON THE FLOOR I DO PASSED
TO ASSEMBLY INSURANCE COMMITTEE
POLITICAL.
S. B..
TWELVE FORTY EIGHT KALRA RIGHT
COLOR AYE VOEPEL.
VOEPEL AYE ALLEN [inaudible]
CABALLERO.
GLORIA.
GLORY I KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KAMLAGER-DOVE I RUBIO
[inaudible]
REVIEW I THE BILL IS OUT.
HIS MUCH I APPRECIATE ALL YOUR
SUPPORT THINK IT WILL KEEP THE
ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS AND
THAT'S WHILE WE WAIT FOR
SENATOR.
JACKSON'S GO BACK ESCULENTA ONE
UP BY WHO HUESO THOSE FILE ITEM
TO SO THAT SOME RUBIO HAS
OPPORTUNITY. TO VOTE ON IT AND
I'M JUST TO MAKE CLEAR ON THAT
ONE HAS TO PASS TO SOME THE
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE I DON'T
THINK I MADE THAT CLEAR THE
FIRST TIME.
SO PERFECT CULTURAL PLEASE.
S. B. ELEVEN NINETY ONE RUBIO
[inaudible]
RUBIO AYE.
THANK YOU AND THEN SO WE'RE JUST
WAITING FOR SENATOR JACKSON
RIGHT NOW I THINK WE'RE
OTHERWISE CAUGHT UP
[inaudible]
YEAH JULIE [inaudible]
GORE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH SENATOR FOR
RUSSIAN GUNS AT YOU THINK THE
SENATOR HAS SOME OF YOU MAY KNOW
AS THE MIDDLE OF A VERY LONG
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE HEARINGS
SHARING SO.
LET'S JUMP RIGHT TO IT FILE ITEM
ONE S. B. TEN TWENTY SIX US
UNDER PLEASE PROCEED WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS --
THIS MEASURE IS THE DIGNITY AT
HOME ACT FALL PREVENTION.
IT SEEKS TO ALLOW MORE SENIORS
AND DISABLED INDIVIDUALS TO AGE
IN PLACE.
AND STAY IN THEIR OWN HOMES
THROUGH THE USE OF SIMPLE
INEXPENSIVE HOME MODIFICATIONS.
THE REDUCE THE RISK OF FALLING.
MEMBERS ONE THOUSAND PEOPLE A
DAY IN CALIFORNIA TURNED SIXTY
FIVE YEARS OLD.
SENIORS HAVE A ONE IN THREE RISK
OF FALLING.
EVERY YEAR OVER THE AGE OF SIXTY
FIVE AND 33% OF ALL FALLS IN THE
ELDERLY POPULATION INVOLVE
HAZARDS AT HOME.
FACTORS LIKE POOR LIGHTING LOOSE
CARPETS AND A LACK OF SAFETY
EQUIPMENT THINGS I GRAB BARS
STAIR RAILS AND HI TOILETS.
ARE A PARTICULAR RISKS. 80% OF
THESE FALLS HAPPEN IN THE
BATHROOM.
THIS MEASURE AUTHORIZES THE
DEPARTMENT OF AGING TO ISSUE
GRANTS TO THE AREA AGENCIES ON
AGING FOR INJURY PREVENTION
SERVICES IN THE HOME. FOR AS
LITTLE AS SEVEN HUNDRED DOLLARS.
WHICH IS THE COSTA FOR TWO DAYS
IN A IN A HOME IN A SENIOR HOME.
THE AVERAGE COST OF A
MODIFICATIONS SEVEN HUNDRED
DOLLARS A HOME CAN BE OUTFITTED.
WITH SIMPLE THINGS LIKE GRAB
BARS OR IMPROVED LIGHTING.
THE SMALL IMPROVEMENTS CAN MEAN
THE DIFFERENCE LITERALLY FOR
MANY SENIORS BETWEEN AGING IN
PLACE.
AND FACING A FUTURE OF
INSTITUTIONALIZATION.
MORE THAN SEVEN HUNDRED THOUSAND
AMERICANS ARE HOSPITALIZED EVERY
YEAR BECAUSE OF A FALL.
MOST OFTEN DUE TO A BROKEN HIP
OR HEAD INJURY.
IN TWENTY FOURTEEN THE LAST YEAR
FOR WHICH WE HAVE DATA.
DIRECT MEDICAL COSTS FOR FALLS
WOULD PATIENTS AND INSURANCE
COMPANIES PAY TOTALED THIRTY
FOUR BILLION DOLLARS.
WITH MEDICARE PICKING UP ROUGHLY
78% OF THOSE COSTS.
CALIFORNIA SURE OF THE SCOTS WAS
FOUR POINT FOUR BILLION DOLLARS.
THIS TO ME IS SUCH AN OBVIOUS.
WAY TO PUT AN OUNCE OF
PREVENTION.
AND EVEN THE POUND OF CURE BY
THE WAY WAS SENIORS IS NOT
NECESSARILY CARE.
THIS IS A TO ME OF IN IMPORTANT
BUT SIMPLE WAY TO DEAL WITH THE
PROBLEM THAT IS.
WITHOUT QUESTION.
AND WHEN YOU KNOW PEOPLE WHO ARE
AGING AND THE RISK OF FALLS AND
NUMBER OF FAWZI IMPACTS AND HAVE
ON THEIR QUALITY OF LIFE THEIR
ABILITY TO LIVE INDEPENDENTLY.
THIS IS JUST SIMPLY A A BILL
WHOSE TIME IS LONG OVERDUE.
AND WITH ME TODAY IS MAXINE MAN
TELL.
REPRESENTING THE NATIONAL
MULTIPLE SCLEROSIS SOCIETY TO
SPEAK IN FAVOR OF THE BILL.
I MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MAXING MEANT HOW
REPRESENTING THE NATIONAL
MULTIPLE SCLEROSIS SOCIETY.
ANA IN SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL
TEN TWENTY SIX MULTIPLE
SCLEROSIS ISN'T UNPREDICTABLE
OFTEN DISABLING DISEASE OF THE
CENTRAL NERVOUS SYSTEM.
AND IT USUALLY DIAGNOSED WHEN
PEOPLE ARE IN THE PRIME OF THEIR
LIFE THE AVERAGE AGE OF ONSET IS
THIRTY FOUR YEARS OLD.
I BECAUSE MS CAN IMPAIR MUSCLE
STRENGTH SENSATION BALANCE
COORDINATION AND GATE.
AND CAUSE SIGNIFICANT DISABLING
FATIGUE PEOPLE LIVING WITH MF
SOMETIMES FIGHT FIND IT
NECESSARY TO MODIFY THEIR HOMES.
STUDIES HAVE FOUND THAT OVER 50%
OF PEOPLE WITH A MASS FALLING
DOWN IN A THREE TO SIX MONTH
PERIOD.
AND 3250% HAVE FALLEN DOWN
MULTIPLE TIMES.
AND OVER HALF THE PEOPLE REPORT
HAVING BEEN INJURED DUE TO A
FILE.
FILES ARE ASSOCIATED WITH LOSS
OF CONFIDENCE AND INDEPENDENCE
SOCIAL ISOLATION CONTROL COULD
CURTAILMENT OF ACTIVITIES AND
CHRIS INCREASED RISK OF MORE
FALSE.
AND INCREASED USE AND COST OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES AND
ULTIMATELY INCREASED RISK OF
INSTITUTIONALIZATION.
SAFETY PRECAUTIONS SUCH AS GRAB
BARS AND SHOWERS INNER TOILETS.
GRAB RAILS ALONG STAIRS REYES
TOILETS LOWERED LIGHT SWITCHES
AND RANCID ENTRANCE DOORS ALLOW
DISABLED INDIVIDUALS CONTINUED
INDEPENDENCE.
AND SAVES MONEY.
BUT HOME MODIFICATIONS ALTHOUGH
VITAL CAN BE ALSO EXPENSIVE AND
OUT OF REACH FOR MANY PEOPLE WHO
NEED THEM.
THE ASSESSMENTS REFERRALS AND
RESOURCES PROVIDED THROUGH
SENATE BILL TEN TWENTY SIX WILL
BE OF TREMENDOUS BENEFIT TO
PEOPLE LIVING WITH MSF WITH M.
ASSN THE MS SOCIETY URGES YOU TO
SUPPORT THE BILL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH A
IS ANYONE ELSE HERE IN SUPPORT.
YES MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
FIRST OF ALL I'D LIKE TO THANK
THE SENATOR FOR CARRYING THIS
IMPORTANT BILL.
TARA KELCH WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF AREA AGENCIES ON
AGING.
I'D LIKE TO SAY YOU KNOW
[inaudible]
IT'S ASSUMED.
THAT FOLLOWING THIS PART OF
GETTING NO.
AND I AM HERE TO SAY IT'S REALLY
NOT.
AND THEY USE THERE'S THINGS THAT
WE CAN DO SIMPLE THINGS AS THE
SENATOR POINTED OUT.
THE KEY PIECE INCIDENTS FROM
OCCURRING.
AND INCIDENTS THAT ARE OFTEN
FATAL.
SO WE HOW STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
BILL AND WOULD ASK FOR YOUR
RIFLE.
AND WILLINGLY ON BEHALF OF THE
COUNTY OF SAN DIEGO IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
VIRGINIA FAIR ON THE TONY I WORK
WITH ARE AN ART STATE SISTERON
SUPPORTED THIS BILL AND THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WHATEVER YOU CAN
DO IF WITH US.
THANK YOU.
HER EVERYTHING.
BRAINIACS CALIFORNIA DISABILITY
RIGHTS A STRONG SUPPORT.
TRUTH ANDERSON WITH ARKAN UCP
CALIFORNIANS PART.
JEAN HER SUMMING UP OF THE
VENTURA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT.
ALRIGHT IRON JEFF TOOK.
IT'S ALRIGHT SHIFT OR DID YOU.
AN ADVOCATE AND HOUSING SOMEONE
IN MY OWN.
HOME IS SO CRITICAL BECAUSE A
AND THEY FELL ON THE TAP SO THEY
WERE HOSPITALIZED THEY STILL
WANT TO LIVE INDEPENDENTLY.
AND FALL PREVENTION AND DID NOT
REALIZE THAT THE AGENT AGENCY.
EVEN THOUGH SUPPLYING THESE
FUNDS AND FALL PREVENTION BUT
THEY'VE NOT BEEN FUNDED SO
SOMETHING THAT CAN DO THAT FALL
PREVENTION.
AS WELL AS THE OTHER
[inaudible]
APPROPRIATE MEANS.
THANK YOU PLACE ANYWAY.
ALRIGHT THE SPRING A BACK MANY
P. DO HAVE A MOTION ALREADY IN
THE TEMAS I HAVE FURTHER COMMENT
[inaudible]
SO MUCH.
THERE'S PEOPLE THAT KNOW ME KNOW
I SELDOM COMMENT BY.
NEVER SPEAK ON THE FLOOR
ETCETERA --
THIS THIS MOVES MY HEART THOUGH
IN SENATOR JACKSON IS ONCE AGAIN
QUITE EXACTLY SPOT ON I WOULD
LIKE.
TO WORK WITH YOU IN THE FUTURE
[inaudible]
ISN'T IT.
ASSUMING WE ALL GET ELECTED WHO
--
IT IT WOULD BE GOOD TO PURSUE
LEGISLATION THAT INCLUDES
HELMETS WHICH I THINK YEARS DOES
[inaudible]
ALSO.
PURSUE MORE MONEY FOR THE GRANTS
TO THE TRIPLE LAYS --
VARIOUS NEURAL CHALLENGES WHICH
HAS ALREADY BEEN MENTIONED
DISABLED VETERANS OUTSIDE THE VA
SYSTEM.
THOSE ARE THE ONES WITH PTSD AND
OTHER DISABILITIES.
HAD THERE NOT BEEN WRONG.
AND COULDN'T CONFORM WITH
MILITARY DISCIPLINE ANYMORE NAY
TEND TO GET DISHONORABLE
DISCHARGES OKAY.
WE NEED TO WORK WITH THEM
BATHTUBS --
ONCE AGAIN I SPENT THIRTY NINE
YEARS NEW INSURANCE BUSINESS
BATHTUBS ARE DEATH TRAPS FOR A
LOT OF SENIORS BECAUSE THEY
CAN'T GET THEIR LEGS OVER --
NON SKID SURFACES.
YOU CAN PUT NON SKID.
IN YOUR HOUSE.
IN KEY AREAS AND SAVE YOUR LIFE
SO [inaudible]
SENATOR.
THIS IS WONDERFUL A BILL I LOOK
UPON IT IS YOU GOT THE FOOT THE
DOOR.
I'LL BE IN THERE TO HELP YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SO MUCH HEAVIER Y. JUST HAD TO
SAY THAT --
I PICKED REALLY APPRECIATE THIS
BILL AND I CAN'T BELIEVE THAT
THERE'S NO OPPOSITION I DON'T
KNOW WHAT YOU DID BUT YEAH WELL
YOU SEE THAT ALREADY STAR THAT
ALWAYS WORRIES ME WHEN I SAY SHE
THE COMMENTS --
THANK YOU SENATOR JACKSON I HAD
A BILL LAST YEAR THAT WAS
REGARDING TAX CREDITS FOR HOME
IMPROVEMENTS WITH PACIFIC
PURPOSE.
AND SO I'M I REALLY APPRECIATE
YOU BRING THIS FORWARD --
I'VE I LIVE WITH MY FATHER WHO
AS MANY OF YOU HAVE MET AND THAT
BREAKS MY HEART WHEN HE FALLS ON
NOT HOME.
AND SO THESE ARE ISSUES THAT I
THINK ALL OF US HAVE DEALT WITH
IN OUR OWN LIVES IN DIFFERENT
WAYS AND IF WE HADN'T WE
PROBABLY WELL.
BY THE WITH OURSELVES OR WITH
OTHERS ARE NOT ONE SO THANK YOU
SO MUCH.
I WISH I CAN MAKE ANY CLOSING
COMMENTS.
JUST TO SAY THAT THEM I
APPRECIATE THAT THE THE CONCERNS
WERE IT CALIFORNIA'S IN AGING
STATE NOW WHERE NEGATIVE BIRTH
RATES THEY WERE SAYING OUR AGING
POPULATION INCREASING
DRAMATICALLY.
IF WE DON'T TAKE STEPS TO
RECKON.
ADDRESS THE CHALLENGES OF AGING
IT'S GOING TO COST THE STATE AN
ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF MONEY THE
RIGHT NOW WE DON'T HAVE.
A AND I'D RATHER SEE US BY DOING
THE PREVENTION AND PUTTING THE
MONEY WE DO HAVE A INTO MORE
CONSTRUCTIVE THINGS THAT ARE
GOING -- TO
REALLY ADVANCE THE STATE BUT WE
ARE AGING AND OUR SENIORS.
AND AND OUR FOLKS WHO ARE
DISABLED WHETHER IT'S BECAUSE
THEY'VE BEEN TO BATTLE WHETHER
THEY HAVE.
A HEALTH ISSUES OWE IT THEY
DESERVE A QUALITY OF LIFE IN
THIS I THINK IS A LEGITIMATE AND
AN IMPORTANT INVESTMENT FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU SO MUCH SENATOR UP.
THAT IF THE ROLE ON THE MOTION
BY SUMMER RUBIO TO PASS OR
SOMETHING APPROPRIATIONS.
S. B. TEN TWENTY SIX KALRA I'VE
KALRA AYE VOEPEL.
VOEPEL AYE ALLEN COVER GYRO.
CAREER AYE GLORIA.
GLORIA AYE KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KAMLAGER-DOVE AYE RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE DEBILIS OUT.
THANK YOU SENATOR CHAIRMAN THEY
CAN THANK YOU I THINK I THINK
EVERYBODY BUT ASSEMBLY COLUMBIA
HAS AT ON IT WITH A COUPLE ON
SO.
I'M [inaudible]
YEAH.
FILE ITEM TWO OF SB.
ELEVEN NINETY ONE HUESO.
S. B. ELEVEN NINETY ONE COVER
THEIR OWN.
COVER YOUR AYE.
ALRIGHT AND THEN --
SP TWELVE FORTY EIGHT A CAN
OPENER ON THAT [inaudible]
BUY GAMES.
S. B. TWELVE FORTY EIGHT
CABALLERO AYE CAREER I ALRIGHT.
AND SO I THINK THAT'S IT.
ALRIGHT WE ARE THEIR JOURNEY
THANK YOU